we want to bring you some breaking news
coming into us from the united states
president joe biden has formally
recognized the massacre of armenians
under the ottoman empire during world
war one as an
act of genocide now this move is likely
to worsen
already frayed ties existing between two
nato allies turkey and the u.s let's get
more from hashem
it's a story more than 100 years old for
turkey
it's a chapter that's turned but for the
united states and other members of the
international community
turkey must apologize for the events
that started in 1915.
that was when ottoman turks deported
hundreds of thousands of armenians from
eastern anatolia to the syrian desert
but what happened and how many were then
killed
remains disputed many historians say
more than a million armenians lost their
lives
turkish officials deny any systematic
killings took place
saying it was time of war and the death
toll
has been exaggerated turkey has always
been angered by
government describing the event that
began in 1915
during the ottoman empire as a genocide
the armenian genocide remembrance day
that takes place in
armenia and is observed by many
armenians abroad on
april 24th every year is widely seen in
turkey
as a western propaganda aimed at
tarnishing the country's reputation
turkey has very strong objections to the
use of the word genocide
they see it as being as linking them to
the holocaust even though these
are two separate atrocities 30 years
apart so that's not really the case they
also worry about some kind of legal
claims against them but again
these are tragic events that occurred
more than 100 years ago so that's very
unlikely the announcement by biden comes
at a delicate moment in u.s turkish
relations
ties between the two nato allies have
been strained for years
in 2020 the trump administration imposed
sanctions against turkey
over its purchase of russian weapons
systems
but trump and turkish president rajaf
erdogan
managed to prevent an escalation and
describe the relationship
as friendly but when biden was elected
president
turkish officials expressed concerns
that might get worse
during the u.s presidential election
campaign last year
when biden was democratic candidate he
described erdogan as an
autocrat and over the last few months
the biden administration has pressed
ankara to improve
its records and human rights with
biden's
latest move the us joins dozens of
countries
that have declared the atrocities
against armenians
more than a century ago an act of
genocide
al jazeera